I'm often given tasks on the fly whereas
many of my tasks are given as a result
of meetings these days an increasing
number are coming from emails or my
manager or client asking me to do
something I find myself quite
disorganized when dealing with this I'm
writing things down when I'm told but
it's all over the place
post-its notebook phone etc I don't have
a solid method of keeping track of these
things I'm guessing that a possible
solution is to write all these things
down in the same place but I've also
tried that and didn't really make a
difference I'd appreciate any input or
advice you have on how to record and
track objectives in a functional in a
reliable manner as I'm subjected to a
lot of information each day week month
I'm definitely overloaded to remember it
myself
discipline equals freedom so yeah a few
things first first of all definitely
write the things down in one place and
it sounds like since you're moving all
the time or you're going to meetings
carry out just a nice little notebook
with you and write the things down as
you get tasked with them then on top of
that you have to have a master list of
some kind either paper or digital I'm
gonna probably recommend digital to
track things overall in a prioritized
method so if you get tasks something in
a meeting in your little notebook you
come back you put it in the right place
in the master task list and then like
twice a day to consolidate the
information that's in the little
notebook you have into the big master
list and then before you go to bed at
night you organize those things by
priority on the master list you put the
most important thing at the top and
that's what you're going to attack the
next day that's part one on how you get
these things organized now the part two
is you've got to schedule this stuff and
actually I always say this when people
have trouble with tasks put them on the
calendar to you know actually Jamie does
that for me when Jamie's got something
for me to do she just doesn't email me
and say hey you need to do this she puts
it on the calendar so I look at my
calendar boom there it is I gotta go do
this what
this task is done so put these things on
your calendar and that includes
scheduling time on your calendar so that
you can have time to consolidate your
list and do a review of your lists you
know whether that takes that probably
take 15 minutes to do and I guess
there's a bunch of apps you can use and
I'm sure people will make
recommendations but there's a ton of
to-do list apps including there's one
there's native ones on all the different
phones so you could look at that as it
possible a voice recorder you can either
use the voice recorder app you have or
you can carry around a little mini voice
recorder then you can just take notes
with that and then you consolidate those
notes from your from your voice recorder
into your master task list every day and
then you just kind of prioritize and
execute it's it pretty straightforward